Bởi vì báo, arsh, arsh, arsh, arsh, nghe, mùi, mùi, tánh chiến trở biết.
Sau của am sát hủ nhằm bờ bù sấu quan chứ thảm ást tại cà ta.
Bà lĩnh đạo không trong này đã đặt đồng thần,
về việc hoàn tất cứ của đàn phản hình bản ửa ca ra.
Thao các đáp ứng yêu cầu cơ bàn của Pia Palestine.
Chúng đòa hảm ást nhấn mạnh điều kiện chấm sức hoàn toàn chiến sử,
và có sự bảo đảm vì việc sức quan, Israel khỏi dạ ra.
Môn tiên cũng tin lộ các cân li là bơi bên trung dàng,
chính đường đối lại trong thời gian tối khi tình hình ăn điên có phần nôn định.
Đồng tháng này, diễn ra dự bất cảnh thẳng theo thang tại xa ca ra.
Chúng anh biết tự dựa qua, hàng chung li như người Palestine đã dựa khỏi thành phố ca ra,
nướng tổng giống người xe tả lên khoảng 2 trong nghiên người.
Chuy đó, lực gần phòng vệ Israel lần đầu tiên ra thông báo,
yêu cầu dây dựa toàn bộ cơ dân thành phố,
mở đường cho một chiến sịch quan sự quy mồ lớn.
Các tổ chứ tế tức tệ tụ cạnh báo nguy cơ cộng hỏi nhân đào,
và kêu khỏi các bên sống đạt được thật tổng bản để bảo vệ sinh thường.